today we're talking about carbon free
energy a new podcast from rsres and the
ultimate guide to speech ai i'm
stephanie wong and welcome to this week
in cloud where we serve you the lowest
latency news securing round-the-clock
carbon-free energy isn't just important
for google it's also critical for the
world to successfully tackle the urgent
challenge of climate change while rapid
progress and cost-effective carbon-free
energy technology has put the prospect
of decarbonized electricity grids within
reach it's not inevitable and that's why
we are committed to working with
stakeholders across the globe to
advocate for policies that accelerate
grid decarbonization for everyone check
out the blog to join us
we're excited to announce the launch of
the google sre broadcast an interview
style podcast where site reliability
engineers at google discuss key sre
concepts and share their experiences
advice and strong opinions along the way
since early 2016 sres at google have
been producing and listening to an
internal version of the broadcast
this year we decided to think bigger and
share insights from google sres with the
wider sre community
thanks to ai speaking out loud has
become not only a primary way of
communicating with machines like when
you tell your smartphone to send a text
or ask your smart speaker about the
weather
but also enriching human interactions
such as generating captions in near real
time during a video meeting
head to the blog to explore some of the
most interesting and practical
applications of speech technology as
well as the google cloud tools that make
building these sorts of apps possible
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link any thoughts or ideas leave
us a comment or tweet us we'll see you
in the cloud